today we are going to the we're going to
a farmers market now if you guys don't
know what farmers markets are I don't
know how to explain it to you
I think it's literally a market or
farmers meet today we have a very
special guest as the sky named Matt Matt
and I haven't known him too long but I
kind of loved Matt story about how he
got into cooking and that's the reason
why I kind of connected with the dude a
lot he's an amazing chef at lux Sean LA
if you guys have ever been there he does
a lot of Asian fusion cooking and today
he's gonna show me what a farmers market
is and basically how to buy poderes from
there and what to look for look at the
the fruit to ryan ratio is [ __ ] crazy
in this pomelo actually really good
they're a lot sweeter than I thought
the melon looked like a a grapefruit but
the only thing I know a pomelo for is
when I go to my Fitness friend's house
and they have it on the alternate like
the Buddhist with all two things I don't
know that [ __ ] was edible I always
thought that was fake
what does that taste like good my name
is Sawa she's my source for knowledge we
had this type of citrus fruit it was
like eleven I remember what it was
called but it was it was a lot sweeter
than I expected I kind of asked her whoa
well how did you think about her what
did it taste like him you know he was
just letting me know it is sweet what
the hell that just blew my mind
homie let me know it was sweet sugarcane
oh yes what you want I first had sugar
King when I was in Hawaii and that's
where we get our sugar from essentially
you just take this woody piece of
fibrous pink and it just you suck on it
or do you chew on it and it has like
this sugary watery taste which is
delicious I think I really like this
there reminds me like young coconut just
something these are radishes they're
called breakfast radishes just look like
these cute little little tiny little
nuts X they were cute nuts X I just said
that so what these do they come from the
earth and they dangle like all sex for
those of you who are not in the know
ballsack carrots come from this country
called testicular juice and in that
country
these things are growth in the earth
when you rip them out and Mother Earth
just screams leave an alcohol ball sac
called Thumbelina curds
I think if I was Explorer you you guys
would have the most [ __ ] up vegetables
on it because I would save everything
ridiculous I will call the ease
testicular fortitude chairs
it's funny cuz when you translate a lot
of like Asian stuff over it's super
literal you know right
and so people can't really grasp their
heads a bit like weird dick vegetable
that's like the actual name was I've now
change it to a dragon vegetable lumpy
dick Paul said ginger Chinese literally
translates to white vegetable see but
now if you guys have ever been to an
Asian restaurant if you look on the menu
we tend to always describe our foods
exactly what they are there's no
artistic flair to it to make it
appetizing and that's the same with our
vegetables for example when you go to a
agen restaurant right
you order a bowl of soup what does the
description say it says knee cap
cartilage and butt-fuck soup and you
expect people to [ __ ] buy that [ __ ] I
mean won't buy it because we're Asian
but when white people see that just I
don't know about that but [ __ ] part
looks like one of those things like I'm
playing Super Mario a lot of Indies yeah
and so when the seeds are dried you can
basic ground it pretty put in chicken
curry I have never had fenugreek before
those are just one of those things that
I saw at the farmers market that I
didn't recognize myself I think girls
ease in when they lack team
oh really a little bit of advice when
you start a relationship and you
establish certain things you have to
continue it for the rest of the
relationship so be careful don't do [ __ ]
for them in the beginning
you